so today i'd like to talk about uh
solving one laplacians which is a slight
generalization of the regular laplacians
which is a zero laplacians and
unfortunately we can only do this in
very special cases with for complex
simplicity complex and then but of
course we can do it fast giving enough
restrictions and the co-authors are
michael cohen uh brittany fosse amir
neri richard pang and there's another
person i'm missing here is that's noel
walkington which i just found out about
but uh i'll have to change the slides
afterwards okay anyway so uh
so all these things really boil down to
simply solving regression right so
regression is you have some data and
you'd like to fit it with some kind of
curve say a line
and then the goal is to fit that data
and i claim that laplacian solvers are
no special thing that's all they're
doing under the hood
so let's uh so in particular right
remember that if you have an over
constrained system you want to solve a
equals b in general you can't solve it
so what do you do you multiply both
sides by the transpose and then you
solve this system and magically the
system um a transpose a is now symmetric
and positive semi-definite and so this
is what makes a lot of this stuff work
okay
and so of course the big question you
know there's huge amount of work in this
conference related to this problem and
that is is can we eventually solve the
general case faster and there's sort of
all the usual starting points on that is
how do we at least reduce the number of
rows and so there was all kinds of nice
work on that okay
so in particular the case uh the
standard case we've been looking at in
these talks so far is what's called
symmetric diagonally dominant and what
that corresponds to then is a a
symmetric matrix for which uh for every
entry the sum of the off diagonals is
is uh less than or equal to the diagonal
okay
and uh so these actually have a nice
correspondence every non
zero entry off the diagonal simply
corresponds to an edge and it's simply
the negation of the way to that edge in
some sense
okay so then there's a huge line of work
on how you solve these starting you know
i went in nearly in your time with
spielman and tang and then some work
with uh
giannis and richard for which we got
down to a single log
i think an important point to point out
is is that
not only can we solve these things fast
sequentially but we get
near linear time algorithms which also
work in parallel so it's not clear how
much parallel you need but at least uh
so a lot of nice problems like the
simplest question is how do you find the
you know uh
single source shortest path than a
possibly negative weight graph it's not
clear how to do that without going
through graph laplacians efficiently and
so those are all special cases for which
you know these solvers can be applied
and so of course the state of the art is
this nice work of richard and dan where
they show that uh in fact not only can
you do these in nearly in your time but
you can do polylog depth so in other
words you can throw out billions of
processors at one of these things
without any problem you just have to buy
the processors but ignoring that problem
uh anyway so that's that's what we know
but
and then of course you know there was
another paper without too many authors
to list here for which we got it down to
a half a log okay
and uh so so let's go on but so there's
another whole approach which we ended up
using for this which is related to this
work of kosc or what they showed then
and lead so that
in fact they don't get as fast as solver
but they solve a very interesting
problem which is
viewing solving symmetric diagonally
dominant or graph laplacians as an
energy minimization problem so it's a
simple context problem and magically
that's just a very nice way to see the
world um and whether it's better or not
that's that's true but it looks like it
it generalizes nicely in the what we'll
talk
okay
so so how should we think of laplacian
well eventually i'm going to want to go
to higher dimensional topology so i'd
like to recouch graph laplacians in
terms of very simple topology
so that we can then generalize it to
higher dimensional topology
okay so the simplest is you look at a
matrix
um which i guess i'm calling b tran b
transpose for some reason we many people
call it just b
but i claim for top logical reasons it's
nice to think of it as b transpose and
then b stands for boundary
okay
so what it is it's a matrix right so
that every column corresponds to an edge
and then it has two entries for the two
endpoints of that edge one plus and one
minus and that corresponds to this case
edge
but actually if you go ahead and you
just put two ones in that that really
doesn't cause a problem all that
corresponds to is symmetric diagonally
dominant systems so in general you can
simply consider these boundary operators
for us we won't actually go back and
consider this case but just to point out
that
that's really the only distinction is
whether you allow both two positive
entries or not um good
so then rewriting the graph laplacian
problem instead of using our the usual b
from now on we're going to use these
partials
and we're going to rewrite this right so
now what happens
is the graph laplacian problem
is what you do then is you take
um this boundary operator and then you
transpose it so this says
we should go from vertice vertices back
to uh edges from edges we should
multiply by some physical quantity like
the conductance and then multiply back
to get some kind of residual to vertices
okay boundary operator and if you want
it's nice to think of writing this this
way and so therefore really all we've
done is uh
we can sort of ignore this constant but
in general throughout the rest of the
talk let's assume that all the
conductors and resistors are one okay
um
good
and so then just rewriting this this
this equation says we want a voltage so
that uh when we convert that to a flow
then that flow has a property that when
you convert it back to a residual to
vertices it meets your demand
okay and this is exactly the regression
problem we started with the beginning so
in some sense we really are just doing
simple regression it's just that we've
restricted ourselves to a very special
kind of matrices for which we can do it
faster okay that's all that's happening
right good
so the important thing here is is that
partial one has at most two non-zeros
per column so its factor width is called
two
right so the very beautiful paper by
dash and spielman i think in 2008 um for
which they show that you can solve any
factor worth two problem quickly okay a
very nice result um which i don't think
is well known and should be but anyway
it's very beautiful be sore okay so of
course the big open question is can we
ever solve anything besides factor we're
too fast
and of course it's not clear i think i
think there were some people i think
aaron and tat will claim that they could
but i was i think not sure the details
the proof that in fact
factor with three is sort of complete in
some sense but i'm not sure it'd be nice
to see that look something like the
reduction from general cnf to three cnf
but it'd be interesting but i think
there's some problem with the number of
variables when you do that but anyway so
that's but anyway so what we'd like to
do then is is the whole point of this is
to try to wander off and look at
problems so factor with more than two
and see if we can still solve them okay
okay so there's some work in this
direction bohm and henrikh mavasa said
that in fact you can solve any elliptic
finite element problem
by reducing it to basically a factor
with two problem preconditioning
okay so this is for um special cases
like the heat equation and stuff and
higher dimension and then dash and
spielman looked at linear elasticity i'm
not exactly sure what
headway they made there but they at
least again tried to look at higher
factor with problems okay so so what
generalization are we going to pick here
what we're going to do is say that
really what we have is our graph really
consists of vertices and edges these are
really just zero and one-dimensional
simplices so we'll now introduce two
dimensional simplices and maybe even
four dimensional simplicities and we'd
like to solve the equivalent problems
okay
um so that was that's the whole goal
good
okay so then what i'm going to do is
actually so to rewrite this so when we
say laplacians the topologists would say
those are zero laplacians and uh what
we're going to look at today are what
are called one laplacians which is one
higher dimension okay good
um
and this is all related to this thing
called helmholtz and hodge decomposition
which we can all view is just related to
the question of whether your flow in a
graph is a circulation or a potential
flow and really that's the same thing
okay
okay and then we'll talk about um what
cases in the one laplacian we can handle
and then we'll discuss the linear time
algorithm good okay
good
so why higher dimension
so you could so so let's just do the
first simple case and of course which is
going to motivate
the stuff the topologists do anyway and
that is really related to navier stokes
for which you have a curl probably
easiest to think of maxwell equation
which you have electromagnetic radiation
in the right-hand rule which says if you
have a current flow this gives you a
magnetic field at right angle so what
happens then how do we then formulate
this
as a discrete version of that and so
that's what the goal is this is
you should just keep in the back your
mind that really we're trying to do some
kind of thing where we have some kind of
right hand rule okay where you
a flow through a triangular face is
going to induce
a circulation on its edges okay and
we're just going to formulate that and
then try to solve that okay
and then whether this is solves
maxwell's equations that's not so clear
um but it should be useful i mean
there's a bunch of restrictions that we
can't do that we don't understand okay
and then later on what i'd like to do is
talk about why that may be related to
social networks okay good
okay
um
okay so
okay
so let's redo the zero laplacian so the
thing that we're missing then in order
to understand that is you really need a
boundary operator that goes from zero
dimensions
to the null to no dimensions okay
and so in that case it ends up being
very simple it's just the let's assume
that remember we have girl laplacian we
think of this as a graph
and
so therefore let's assume the graph is
connected otherwise it's slightly more
complicated
and then what happens now is as i claim
the boundary operator is simply just the
all ones operator it simply takes your
vertices and just takes the sum of the
values at the vertices and returns that
sum okay
this gives you a natural operator which
you end up calling that which uh the
topologist called down and the reason is
is because you start with something of
dimension zero you go to something of
dimension minus one or whatever and then
you go back up to dimension
zero again right so in our case this is
just then a matrix of all ones right
this is a big
dense matrix and then there's the up
operator which is our standard laplacian
here
and then when you combine them you get
the nice property this is then called
the zero laplacian and this is the mix
of the two and why is this nice is
because this now has uh
is uh non-singular okay so the beauty
now is we've sort of in in a clean
topological way allowed us to handle the
null space problem which
we didn't we if you notice we always do
in a sloppy way we sort of push it under
the rug okay that's what the topologist
tried to do and in higher dimension
that's going to be important okay
so then of course now let's let's
understand this in a very pedantic way
so how do you solve this equation now
well you have a v
a potential or a voltage and you're
trying to reach some residual
so again what you do is you say well
d can be written as a direct sum of a of
an up and a down
where the down is simply
simply returned i guess there should be
a superscript here
um it simply returns the sum of the
values at the vertices right and so that
should be uh that's how much uh
that's how much we should remove from
this and then and then when we remove
from that that gives our d up and then
we just solve this equation right so
this is our just the classic thing we
always do right you simply remove
you make sure that the demand has the
property that
that the sum of the demands is zero
right and this is just a pedantic way of
saying that right okay good
and so that's what we want to do
okay
right and so what makes all this work is
this very nice property
that if you take the boundary operator
one and then apply the zero you get zero
okay
so in particular it's equivalent to
saying that the kernel of this map
contains the image of the other map and
in particular in our case when the graph
is connected we get equality okay
and so all this stuff really is very
fancy
but you know if you've taken strange
linear algebra course which i think is
required at mit and you look at chapter
three this is what's called the four
fundamental subspaces theorem okay so
it's all very simple stuff it's not
really anything fancy okay good
okay so from now on we're gonna have
simplices zero and one two and three
dimensional
and we're gonna use names
vertices edges faces and cells
and so in general we're going to have
some kind of triangulation so our
triangulation is going to be some messy
thing that looks like this here right so
it's going to have
edges vertices and tests
okay good
so then what we want to do let's start
using fancier terminology so a zero
chain then is a map from vertices to um
the reals so this is the one we talked
about the partial operator you have
values of your vertices and it returns
in our case simply the sum of the values
you have another operator that um
takes you one change which takes you
from it which no i guess these are just
uh scalars so it simply assigns values
to the vertices this one assigns values
to the edges and then we'll have another
one that assigns values real numbers to
the faces okay and then you could
imagine similarly for tests and so quite
often we call these potential voltages
or residual flows
these are flows and then we'll call
these fluxes because the way we're
thinking of this right is we're thinking
of the value here being how much flow
or electric current flows through this
triangle right so okay
okay and then we have operators that go
between these right
so uh in particular then our partial two
then takes us from two chains to one
chains partial one takes us from one
change to zero chains right this is all
sort of standard good another nice way
to think of this is really have a post
set you have a complex and you have a
boundary operator that takes you from
top from to uh faces to edges to
vertices back to the components right
okay
and so we have these nice maps
here and there and now the critical fact
is that we it's we're required when we
set up this map that these this property
is true that remember we we have this
plus or minus ones running around on the
edges
and and throughout the whole map we have
to decide on the right sign and the
critical thing is to set it up so that
this is actually true so that everything
works right so this is what we this is
required of us right
good and of course that's equivalent to
saying this good
okay
and so then the question is there's a
slight question here is when we put one
of these chains on the right hand side
should we call it residuals or demand or
potentials right and when we put it on
the uh on the left hand side of an
equation let's call it a flow okay good
so then what is partial one well again
it consists of two parts it consists of
a down operator so what's this right so
this says you take a flow on your on
your graph
you redu you from that you compute a a
set of potentials and from that you
generate a flow okay so this takes you
from flows to flows this says the same
thing this says it takes a flow on the
edges it returns fluxes on the faces and
from the fluxes on the faces it returns
back a
set of flows on the edges so both of
these operators then take you from flows
to flows okay
good
and of course these are very dense
difference because notice that this is a
potential flow where this is a
circulation
so what if the the reason we're dividing
these up very carefully is is that this
operator is computing the potential part
of the flow and this operator is i mean
is looking at it and this operator is
looking at the circulation part right
sorry
the first one i believe
so so these are
yeah so these are also uh you're saying
that that the image is determined by
this right so this so no matter what you
put here you're only going to return a
potential flow right
space
yeah so it's going to give you into the
flow so you can also view it right so
it's projecting right and so we need the
second one
this one here
right so let's see i think i have more
slides let's see no let's uh so so that
what this is doing here right is it says
uh this operator says
the way to think of it is you have some
kind of triangulated space
and you have a flow on the edges so that
flow on the edges is going to induce a
flux on the face
right
so what happens then is if you have
if you have a triangle here
and and i put some number of units of
flow alpha on this edge
that's going to induce a flux of size
alpha here right for the unit case right
okay
so i mean the other way to think of it
is you know
physics which i should really understand
right it says that if you have right an
electrical flow on the edges that's
going to induce a magnetic flow right
good
and then on the other hand once you have
this magnetic flow so then what's going
to happen now that's going to then
induce some other stuff here
so you're going to get some beta and
then what you're going to do then is
combine these back to get something on
this edge right
so just very similar so
topologically so it's just i claimed
mechanically what we did for graphs
what'd we do for graphs we did exactly
the same thing right we took
a
we took a potential a value on the
vertices from that we generated a flow
on the edges from the flow on the edges
we return to residual
right
good
and so that was quite a projection that
delta
well i think uh
it can't be a projection yeah let me let
me i think what we want to do is do a
projection let me just go on so what's
going to happen
um
is what i want to claim is this is
what's true right and that is if you
look at the image of these two operators
they're orthogonal
right
and i claim in the case whatever this
means that of beta is zero this is the
helmholtz decomposition
that we get
that in fact is the whole space
so in some sense
um
rejections right i think in the end
these are right
they weren't in the early lower
dimensional case so
yeah let's see
i think that we require to do the
projection before we started right in
some sense right we removed the part of
the potential which we didn't sum to
zero and then we went back and solved it
so that's what's going to happen here so
what we're going to need we'll do is
we'll we'll do some kind of projection
um
so so another interpretation to this is
what's really happening here is that um
the image of this thing here of course
is contained in the image of this map
but notice that this map has the
property that it turn returns the
circulation for each face so it's a sum
of circulation so it is a circulation so
this returns some kind of
circulation on the edges
on the other hand this operator here
returns something that's a potential and
in this case we get i guess all
potential flows right
so what's happening here is is that uh
it's decompo this
these things are returning these two
different types so what's going to be
crucial then is is that we can break the
solution up into solving two separate
problems right the up and the down
separately
similarly to what we did in the gra and
the zero laplacian case since that's
what's going to happen right
okay
so so there's a very nice
nice exercise to give in a graph theory
class and that is that um if you take
the all the flows on a graph
that in fact you could look at those
that are circulations and those are in
fact orthogonal to potential flows for
unit size resistors and in fact there's
another nice exercise to show that in
fact it spans all flows so the set of
all flows can be written uniquely as a
potential flow and a circulation
which is uh sort of a fact that somehow
gets used but somehow i don't think we
prove it directly usually right
but anyway so um
so that's what's going to make this all
work right it's really we're decomposing
these flows into two kinds
good
so so let's go back to the chaos z
algorithm so what do they do at a high
level what they do is that they solve a
dual problem right so they're trying to
find a zero potential something to put
zeros here for whether that helps right
to meet some given demand or residual
and so the way they do that then is they
solve this dual problem which they say
i'm looking at all flows which meet the
demand right so i simply replace this
this term here with the flow
and i i look for that flow and then i
just ask for one of minimum energy so
it's a classic thompson's principle or
whatever for
electric electricity right so instead
they just solve this problem instead
okay good
um
so uh
and and they do one
another sort of very simple trick and
that is they say okay i want to solve
this problem so how should i do that why
don't you just start by finding any old
flow that meets the demand and then why
don't i then just
add a circulation
until i minimize the energy
so at a high level this is a kosz
algorithm so then all they have to do
then is is of course they have to figure
out how they're going to do this but
ignoring that for the moment then they
just solve this right they find any old
flow and then they will try to find one
of min energy okay good and so uh we're
going to try to use the same piece of
technology
okay
so for ours we're going to do the same
thing right
so what do we do first of all we
we want to solve
solve this equation so what do we need
to do
so by the helmholtz
um what we do is we first of all wanted
to break our demand up so of course our
demand here now is a flow so we want to
break our flow up into a circulation and
a potential flow okay
so um
and so what we'll do is we'll do that
i'll worry let's worry about that later
and so once we figure out the the
circulation part of our demand then what
we'll do is this then we'll find any
other
flux on the faces which meets that
demand and then what we'll do is we'll
cycle through all those
fluxes which
will cycle through all those fluxes for
which we minimize the energy okay
and so that's going to be how we're
going to go about solving this right
what we're going to do then is
just apply kosc idea and that it says
find some
flux which meets the demand it may not
be a min energy one and then we'll
simply then add in
more flux to try to minimize the energy
okay so it's just trying to cut just do
their
their trick over again in higher one
higher dimension okay
so but the first thing we need to do is
we need to take this demand which is an
arbitrary flow and we have to write it
then as a decomposition into
a circulation and a uh
potential flow this is very classic but
let me just go through that so this is
where the projection would come in right
so the first we need to compute let's
compute the down part
okay
so uh i claim when you work that out
that's just a simple projection operator
right you simply then compute
you you uh take your demand and uh your
flow
right and then you
convert it to to a residual then you
apply the inverse operator and go back
this is just a classic formula for um
projection operator so i claim when you
do this but of course this inner term
here the only hard part is is solving
this this system and that of course is
just a zero laplacian which we know how
to do so therefore we can do this right
so then quickly we can figure out how to
compute d down and then if we want d up
within we just assuming there's no error
we simply subtract this from our d then
that gives us our d up so we simply then
do a very classic thing of decomposing
our demand which is now a flow into a
circulation and a potential flow good
and uh and then we just solve the two
problems separately right good
um so then the hard question now is okay
so now we have
we have our our circulation and we need
to then go back then and and find
some flux
um
which meets this demand
so the interesting problem here is
topologically this all of a sudden
becomes quite interesting because in the
1d case
what do we do we simply take a spanning
tree
and
it's very easy to see that you can
always
find
a
flow on that spanning tree which meets a
given set of demands at the vertices
simply because it's a spanning tree in
it and it basically you can apply
gaussian elimination right it's upper
triangular right it's what's going to be
here case here it's going to be very
hard and what we're going to have to do
is
there's very few theorems known about
this but there's a very nice theorem of
chillingsworth who proves that if you
have a complex 3d simplicial complex
that in fact there is a way to do it in
that case that is what's called
collapsible
okay and so that's going to allow us
then to find some flow that meets the
demand and in some sense that seems to
be the hardest part of this whole thing
it'd be nice to have some better ideas
for that okay um
so
so suppose um
that we have found some fl flux that
meets our circulation demand right
good
um
did i script the slide loop
okay okay
so then how are we going to do this so
suppose we found um
some flux that meets our demand good
so now what are we going to do so now
we're going to look at all other fluxes
okay
subject to this condition but i think
this condition is trivial in um
so this so so now we're going to look at
all of the the fluxes for which it's
zero
right so which it produces a zero flow
and we're going to try adding this to
our system to minimize the energy okay
and then it's not too hard to see that
this is equivalent to our original
problem good
um but now we'll use a simple trick here
at least to make it work in this case
and that is to say well
let's assume that we are in some kind of
place where beta beta two was zero in
other words all that we're saying is is
that
it's the case that um
we can pick up all flows all
circulations as some some
combination of fluxes okay so that's
what beta0 says it just says this well
assuming that this is true then this
simply says that this
this um
this flux can be obtained in one higher
dimension by just looking at potentials
on the the tets such that uh when you
apply partial three to it you get um
that particular flux right
so let me just draw a quick picture here
so that's just simply saying the
following
and that is
all right we're trying to get
we're trying to get some kind of uh flux
coming out of this face here
one way to get that is is what we do is
we have some kind of value in inside
here
say heat and then we just
apply that and that gives us then fluxes
on all the faces right
coming out so
so what i'm assuming here is is that
um
we're able to obtain all the the fluxes
right
with zero with this property
as simply
um having potentials on the tests
so this means assume that there is
actually
a bunch but you start with a bunch of
tetrahedra yeah so we're assuming for
simplicity so what we're assuming now is
that we have a 3d simplicial complex
and so not only that but but on these
tests
we're also given uh
so so the tets are nice in the sense
that right we can generate that this is
true right namely that if you look at
all the flexes for which they generate
uh
no circulation
right that those can be obtained as
simply
applying uh having a
you know
pressure or whatever inside each tet so
is that what correspond to this being
simply connected yeah i think it
corresponds so in our case let's do the
simplest case is that it's a simply
connected ball right so for instance
it's a ball
right
obtains right
this is what's usually cosmology in
politics we're saying homology is
trivial
yeah so so i think the equivalent to
saying the homology is trivial that it's
a basically a ball okay so does betty
one equal zero say that a graph is a
tree is that connected it's
okay
just that it's connected is that all
yeah so
so it only makes sense to talk about
it at the level where um like it doesn't
make sense to talk about
a tree whether the homology there until
you introduce what the faces are
so i think beta zero correspond to
connected beta one corresponds to that
it's something that looks like a sphere
right
and uh and and beta three corresponds to
being a ball
right
yeah
i think the betty numbers are just the
different kinds of cycles you can get on
the surface
so as so a ball is back in number it's
very number zero
if you get the bending number to be one
you get a taurus so you have two kinds
of cycles that don't you can't like melt
one kind of cycle into the other kind
and that's what so it's just tracking
like overall global structures in this
shape
oh so uh
so assuming that we have all these
properties which would be nice to get
rid of then then we can now go back and
make the following substitution in this
equation we can substitute in here this
term here into this equation and try to
solve it
right so now let's assume that we we
have you know a flux which meets our our
uh
demand the circulation let's assume that
beta two betty two is zero then then
really we're trying to minimize this
equation okay
good
and uh what i claim then is is that
minimizing this corresponds to solving
an equation that looks like this
okay
for some um
for some d3 okay
so let's uh let's see that that's sort
of trivial so we're trying to minimize
this term here
i'm not sure this is necessary whether
this is confusing but we just expand
this product here and we get three terms
right we're going to get a term a
constant term we're going to get a
linear term in f3 and we're going to get
some kind of quadratic term and in f3
right if we compute the gradient for
these things here of course this is
going to go away this term here becomes
just a constant this term here becomes
linear in f3
and so if we set this to zero now we're
just trying to solve an equation that
looks like this where um d3 is this term
here
our claim that solving this thing so if
we try to minimize this
all we need to really do is be able to
solve equations of this form
faster
not necessary it wasn't clear i'm sure
it's
either to do the
one laplacian
you don't need to go to solving an
equation on faces so why do the two
laplacian do we have to go to solving an
equation on
oh because we're going to dualize it and
claim we're back to uh zero laplacians
because that's all we know how to do i
mean our problem is is that in some
sense we did a fourier we wandered off
in this direction tried to prove
something interesting and then what we
did is cobbled together as much as we
could so that they was publishable right
so i mean that's the way to think of it
at a high level right
and uh and that worked
so that but but still on the other hand
you know you somehow if you're going to
go off on this you need to say something
interesting otherwise they don't let you
publish a paper but it's still i think
non-trivial right
the the people that do you know physics
and stuff like that simulations say they
had never seen this before okay so
that's interesting okay so so so did
everyone agree then that if we go back
then
to doing this
if we want to solve if we're given
right so if we're given a flux that
meets our uh demand
and we're trying to to minimize this
equation it suffices to simply solve
something that looks like this
right
well what does this correspond to this
corresponds to and
so what i claim is that if we have a 3d
simplicial complex that if we're trying
to solve this this just dualizes right
because what is this this simply says we
have the value in the middle of every
tet
right
and what are we trying to do we're
trying to generate
values
what does this say here right this says
we have the value of each one we need to
then find values on all the uh
the faces so those correspond to edges
so maybe just try that as a dual here
um right
so we have this picture now that looks
something like this right there's this
cat
right
and uh it has a dual
vertex inside going out through each of
the faces
right coming out here
here and there's another one here
somewhere else right so the under the
hood here is this
degree 4 vertices vertex and what are we
trying to do here we're trying to find
values here we're trying to find a value
here
at these guys
right
which have the property that
when you view that as a flow on these
edges
right
that's
this part here and then you go back
and you take those flows and you look at
the residuals at the vertices
you get what you wanted right
so this
is precise this and if we dualize it as
this equation here
so we're back to where we started and
then we can use the same hammer right so
then the hammer then just says oh well
since we're we've we've made a huge
number of assumptions about being a 3d
completion complex and all kinds of
other things magically it boils back to
our
something we know how to solve
so there's just a zero laplacian and
then we're home free
okay
good
but so the interesting point on all this
so this is all nice you know we threw in
a lot of assumptions be nice to get rid
of those but we still have this other
interesting problem here and that is how
did we ever get any old flux that meets
our demand
unfortunately that ends up being
interesting um
good
so there was a whole
um work in the 50s by whitehead on
what's called collapsible complex okay
and
so
so there's a thing called edge
collapsing so an edge collapsing is
something we see all the time so if you
have some kind of graph with a vertex of
degree one
good a collapsing then topologically
simply says you remove the vertex and
the edge but the way we think of it is
you're in the middle of a solve so you
have some residual you'd like at this
node and you have a single edge here
well the only way you're going to get
that residual there is by applying the
appropriate amount of flow on that edge
so therefore topologically you can think
of doing this but under the hood you can
think of it as you're in the middle of
trying to figure out the flow
on that edge to meet a given demand good
so equivalently you can do the same
thing here so suppose now you're trying
to have a given circulation on the edges
of a gra of a triangulation
and you're trying to figure out how much
flux to put on the faces to meet that
demand well if there's only one edge on
this
uh if there's only one face common to
this edge the only one that's going to
give you the flow on this is this face
so therefore you're forced to set the
flux here to be equal to the flow you
want on that edge and then when you
remove it of course then you have to
update it and readjust
the the demands on the remaining edges
but you can keep going in that fashion
okay
good
okay so of course you can do the same
for solids right if you have for
instance um
you're trying to get a given flux on
this face
and it happens to be only uh common to a
single pet
then you can simply then you have to set
the value in that tet
to meet the the value you want on that
face right good
so but this lends itself to a very nice
topological question then is you know
when can you take some kind of
topological structure and get this to
happen okay
good
okay
um
good so there's certain kinds of things
that are collapsible so in particular
this this here is a collapsible it's a
tree this is also collapsible if you
check it out you can just go through and
remove them all this is not right if
you're missing these faces you can't
collapse this
okay
of course uh what would happen then of
course what do we what does uh
um you know what lr uh you know lorenzo
and crew do they would say well of
course you wouldn't keep all these edges
because you don't need that many in
order to meet the demand you would just
take a subset of those edges which
formed a tree and you would use that you
would jettison the extra edges right
so the question is you know how do you
how fast can you decide whether a 3d
simplicial complex is collapsible and
also how do you determine if it has a
subcomplex
that allows you to meet the demands and
is still collapsible
sorry what's the difference between us
between this one here
this has a gray here and this is white
i saw that
i know i i just couldn't resist sorry um
that so that means that this is a
triangle in the complex this one has
this is not a triangle in the complex
you don't have the face it's missing
yeah
it's just a skeleton right
okay that's the distinction things sorry
okay
so um how do you even decide if it's
collapsible let alone whether a
subcomplex right well it's np hard to in
general for a three complexes there's
there's a whole crew of people that
worry about this stuff and they have all
kinds of negative results so the
question is of course how to get
positive results that seems to be harder
and there's a bunch of np hardness
results in this way right it's open for
three balls right however you can decide
okay
but there's a very interesting result
but from way back in the 60s that said
that if you have a
a
convex triangulated
uh body
okay so in other it's a bunch of tests
which have been glued together to form a
convex body then that is actually
collapsible
right
and it's actually non-trivial the proof
is quite quite clever actually you have
to actually do something to to make sure
you don't get in trouble because
remember we didn't say anything about
what the shape of these tets are right
this is an arbitrary mess
if you have uh
yes you have any substituted composition
proper simplicity composition of the
synthetics yeah i have a contact simpler
simplex right take take a convex
polytope in 3d
and triangulate the interior
right
then that's collapsible
that's what this theorem says
right
and the reason it's non-trivial is
because you know you have to be careful
what order you you do this right so of
course you would start by removing some
outer face and and one of the and the
ted it's common too but you have to be a
little careful how you do that right and
but anyway he was able to show that that
works right so this is a top logical
result so it's not obvious to me like
convexity is important
is there an interpretation yeah yes
um but if you go through the proof it's
very it comes in very
in the way he does it right he has to be
very careful
um so
there was time
when i was helping the liberals
a lot of those livers he said you know
often this liver flow to the boundary
then it doesn't matter anymore it's
really lazy
yeah i don't know
so by the way note this is not a purely
topological thing right you can have two
synthetic complexes that represent the
same topological space
and one of them is um you know for
example three balls that's one
topological space there are lots of
triangulations
and one of them can be collapsible and
one of them can't
so
it's a kind of like
combinatorial property too
so commentarial i guess i was assuming
by topology we meant commentarial
topology right
but if if you're not then it's different
right so that's not so clear okay
um
okay
so and and then yeah and i guess as we
just said this is all correspond to
gaussian elimination right so in fact
has a nice interpretation so of course
when you rem if in the middle of this
thing here you know we we uh
we're applying this operator when we
remove an edge
right this corresponds to doing some
kind of a gaussian elimination right and
notice when we do this and we drop a
face what we're really doing is dropping
one of the uh columns in the matrix so
it has a very simple interpretation
because these are higher dimensional in
the particular case we're doing right
so they have very natural
interpretation okay good
okay
so now they're sort of the question is
just in case you hadn't thought about
this um
if you there's the obvious simple cases
to work out is what happens if you have
a triangulated sphere
okay
so if you take you know your favorite uh
sphere
and uh you get in and it's been
triangulated for you right so that
there's these triangles
right
good so this is a one of the complexes
okay
so then what i want to claim is is that
of course it's not collapsible as the
whole thing goes right
because there's no edges that are um
on a single face but if what you do now
is is you remove one of those faces
right then it becomes collapsible
and also it's not too hard to prove it's
a nice exercise using euler's formula to
show that in fact
the remaining faces have the property
that
they generate their circulations
generate all circulations on here right
so it works out just perfectly right
good
so then the next interesting question is
what happens if you take something like
a projective plane
so and this is a nice exercise also to
work out i think nathan lineal was
playing with this stuff for some other
reason and you end up with a similar
kind of thing so in case you forgot what
a projective plane is
rejection of a plane is where you take a
disc and you identify opposite points so
for instance this is x x
y y
z z
okay
and now what happens here is this is a
nice triangulation again same as before
but unfortunately you don't have enough
triangles so so what happens in this
case if you work it out you need all the
faces to get all the circulations you
can't throw any of them out and if you
don't drain your mouth it's not
collapsible okay so this gives you one
that's sort of stuck i think there's a
simple solution you just take the double
cover of this
and then you work in some higher
dimensions similar to the symmetric
diagonally dominant systems but
work that out okay so so it's
interesting that very simple things
happen there's all kinds of other much
more complicated things there's things
all the duns have and all kinds of other
topology things that are
um much more complicated it wasn't clear
okay okay
so so in the last few minutes let me
just
claim that uh
you know
most most of us here are not really that
interested in doing physical simulations
um because there's a slightly more money
in other things like social networks and
all so let's try to maybe sell this as a
social network thing okay go to first
cut so i claim that triangles come up
quite often in social networks it
there's a huge number of papers on this
whole area of finding all the triangles
in a social network magically this is
very useful for all kinds of reasons
right there's a there must be a hundred
papers
on first of all counting triangles but
also why you would want to know the
number of triangles and this somehow
tells you all kinds of things about a
social network okay so that's the first
thing
there's actually papers by target and
crew where they showed and i think jacob
one of the students when he worked at
facebook said that in fact clustering
based on triangles seem to give better
results in other words what you do is
you start by taking your social network
you find all the triangles in it and you
glue two triangles together if they
share an edge and then you use that to
cluster and as i understand i i don't
think there's any proof of any of this
that that somehow gives a much better
way of doing social network clustering
okay okay
um recently there's a uh student bob
this has showed that uh so the other
question is what you'd really like to do
in social networks is find cliques
well first of all
chances are there may be an edge missing
in some large clique and so then it's
not any longer a clique but so what
you'd like to do is sign something that
looks like a clique so the simplest of
course is what you do is you try to
maximize the number of edges to vertices
in in a sub graph
unfortunately that gives you things that
are too big
so what he did is he went back and he
said well let's count the number of
triangles to the number of nodes in the
subgraph
and magically that gives you something
much better and it's still computable in
polynomial time okay
so
so so those are all things that are well
known let me ask you a question that i
don't know and that i think would be
interesting um and that is are the
eigenvectors or values of our one
laplacians of social networks useful
and there should be some equivalent
version of a cheeker kind of theorem
for social networks or at least it'd be
nice to know why not right
so if you compute these eigenvectors is
that interesting
right and uh
and if not then that may say that this
is the wrong approach for this whole
thing
i have seen cheater inequalities for the
entire order of laplacian that's already
been done so that's good i don't
remember
okay i'll find the reference right no
that'd be nice okay okay and i think
that's it
okay
okay thank you
i
think questions
more time for coffee
i should expect that if you if you do
some kind of a clustering based on this
eigen vector
yeah yeah because somehow it's going to
be assigning our values to vertices to
uh triangles
and so then you can sort the triangles
by that easy direction of some kind of
inequality
yeah well that's that's the first
question right i mean is that even
interesting to sort i mean the obvious
thing is is you sort the triangles by
their value right and roughly that's
what tiger says to do right
and then you do something with that
right if you sort the
the vertices the triangles by that is
that tell you something interesting
about the social network
i think that's the first actual question
so gary i am interested in social
networks but i am maybe in exception in
this room also interested in scientific
computing
so so uh so what pdes uh are amenable to
this style of of thinking
yeah so that's why there's this other
co-author like noel walkington who is a
numerical analyst and and we found this
big huge book you can find very big fat
books on things like doing uh maxwell's
equation because that's critical in
radar right i mean the critical thing in
radars you need to figure out whether
there's a plane in there or whether
that's you know some other kind of thing
a duck and so somehow you need to do
those things and uh so these
calculations would be very important but
we never got
enough into the book to figure it out
other than there is a slight problem and
that is normally when you're doing radar
what you do is you have a convex ball
that's fine
but you also have a hole in the inside
where the airplane is right
and so you need to be able to work in
some kind of a
annulus
so that's so then there's all these nice
topological questions so what we really
need to do is find five more co-authors
that really have a good handle on
topology and then maybe we can make
headway this issue of simplicial nested
rom complexes and all this stuff
it's a relatively hot topic in numerical
visualizations for pdes these days
and so and so
language they use is similar to what you
were of course i mean you borrowed it
from them um
and it's not an area i have expertise in
but i certainly have access to people
who do have expertise
yeah it'd be fun it'd be fun to sit down
with someone for which you know the
language
you know barrier isn't too big
and and and discuss this right and so
that the hope is there's like maybe one
possibility is with null or someone like
that
be able to have sort of a three or four
way conversation
trying to understand also it'd be fun to
bring in an apologist because i'm not
sure the first cut they worry about
you know these messier kinds of
questions like collapsibility and stuff
like that right i mean somehow i think
the book that he found some there's very
big famous book on this stuff
and didn't worry about
this particular aspect of it right
i mean making an entering heart is good
yeah until like someone like have
herbert involved right
10 years ago he's continuing to make
this a claim which i uh clearly i can't
because condition he basically said any
of the slippers floating to the surface
that imagine
he just literally said that way and uh
well
he didn't explain yeah but it seems like
this
surface while you can somehow peel it
off because it sounds like like yeah i
don't think i mean yeah so the trouble
is is then you look at these things like
you know the duns have which i still
haven't got my head around right
you know and uh just it's interesting to
look it up when you go online right i
mean there's also good youtubes on that
but anyway so it's just simply a single
triangle where you identified all three
sides back on itself
called the duns hat
and that's very complicated right let
alone anything else right
there's bing's house and
the the the
let's see
all
all the aspect ratio are good except the
one that you can
somehow
collapse
so somehow you have a chance for that to
lead you to
a a new one that has good aspect that
does it has a numerical
uh
system yeah i don't see how just
throwing in the fact that all the tets
are nice is somehow going to solve the
problem i'm a little worried that it's
you know more subtle than that
numerical stability right because it has
a nice normal disease
it has nothing to do
yeah but but somehow we need something
stronger here right we need you know
somehow
i just how do you find a flow and my
feeling is there's probably some other
tricks that make this stuff work we're
just there there must be you know more
ideas how you do this adding other tets
or some other kind of i mean it's not
really clear
whether it hurts to add other stuff to
the system or not right
you know i i can just imagine this is
wide open we're just not very
imaginative what should be done
are the questions social networks
that's probably more interesting
let's have a coffee